[Music]
so with all that said then what do you
do about the religious people because if
I was to take I don't want a new atheist
I think it attacked a lot often unfairly
I think because people just pick there
they think that they're so mean and
they're trying to destroy religion and
they hate religious people I very rarely
have ever seen that I think they attack
the ideas of religion which as you know
I would say should be a tactic like any
other idea there is but going under this
this Objectivist ideology what do you do
with the religious well how do they fit
into a society I don't think you're
trying to exterminate them or even fully
they're certainly not the people but but
even the ideas of religion I don't sense
that you you'd prefer I suppose that
they are crumbling but not know I want
to recrawl there's no question I wanted
to crumble I don't try to be nice I wish
I know you an excellent I know but I
know I want them gone and but there's
only one way to do that and that's
education education education to speak
its tits the reason with people and and
I think my whole project everything I
believe in is to some extent dependent
on the demise of religion uh you know I
don't think without the enlightenment
and the beginning of the demise of
religion in the 18th century you would
have had a United States of America I
think the United States of America is a
secular achievement I mean counter to
all the religious why you claim it's
that it's the culmination of a
judeo-christian there's nothing
judeo-christian about them you guys are
going to Texas on a dinosaur yeah and in
the old testament of individual rights
or the right to life liberty and because
if your happiness I mean it's not there
right it this is the this is the
achievement of human reason of
secularization of the idea of relegating
religion to your private life which is a
which politically is enough right so we
can have a free society if we say
religion is relegated and you can't
bring it into the public square but that
never happens right evangelicals are not
just going to sit there and say we're
never going to go into politics as we
see today and as we've seen for last 40
50 years they're very involved and they
were in the 19th century very involved
in political life so and they bring
religion into the public square at they
and I also the other thing is I'm not in
this for politics right politics is is a
is is the outcome it's great if
we get to live in a really free society
that would be so cool I mean much more
important as what we started out the
conversation with because the impact I
can have and these ideas can have on an
individual human being in making that
individuals like better so to me the
Objectivist ethics the Objectivist Moll
code is much more important to me than
all the politics and capitalism and all
this the suffrage the capitalism is just
an outcome of that so I partially I want
to see demise of religion because I want
to free those religious people from what
I think of barriers to their own success
and their own happiness and partially
because I think that the truly free
society cannot exist as long as a
significant number of people take the
religion seriously I think religion is
anti freedom at its core and the more
seriously they take their religion or
less free will be so so I want to get
rid of religion but I realized that
that's good gonna take forever it's
going to take a long long time decades
centuries maybe in the meantime it
convinced as many people as I can bring
in these idiots i people writing to me
and they sign it christian Objectivist
and then i have jewish objectives him do
it anybody thinks they religion and
objectivism are the same right I'm gonna
rip fine so my view is I'd rather have
you being a Christian Objectivist than a
Christian Christian right I'd rather
have you adopt certain ideas from
objectivism into your Christian
framework then not adopt any of the
ideas so to the extent that I can they
can impact people's lives even if they
don't embrace everything that I say
right and it's a little spooky if we sit
here and talk and somebody says yeah I
agree I've never heard of your honor I
think Iran just said right I know go go
read a little bit go study right because
all I'm trying to do to you and in my
public talks is just get people thinking
yeah and then if they read and then one
day they come to the conclusion I was
right cool but I you know people are
convinced by one lecture one talk and
it's scary to me a little bit because if
that Association thing is kind of funny
because the phrase well I don't agree
with everything he says I thought people
say that all the time now implying that
if you even say something nice or you
like a tweet of someone that will
obviously endorse
everything that they've ever said ever
so I so I appreciate that you're saying
that but I know you're not just saying
it because I've been to several these
events that you guys put on in and
colleges and I said we're going to do a
whole bunch of come this fall but the
the wide variety of people in diversity
of thought there was plenty of diversity
and all the other stuff too but in the
diversity of thought so it wasn't as if
well those Objectivist they only said
they were there over there who said they
were believers well I talked to most of
people I think 90% of the people that I
actually speak in front of know either
don't know anything about what I'm going
to say or violently disagree hopefully
how violently but they disagree
intellectually fundamentally with what I
say and I just I have to say I enjoy
speaking to hostile audiences much more
than I enjoy speaking to objectives on
ok you know they can agree with what I
said I can push the envelope a little
bit here a little bit there I can
stimulate them a little bit but to see
an audience that comes in hostile and
and at the end of the day is a little
respectful of the ideas because I've
said something and I've said it in a way
that resonates with them and they go
alright so maybe I need to think about
this again that to me is so much more
fun and so much more interesting and so
much more world-changing at the end then
just talking to the converted if you
will and talking to people so I love I
love being challenged by young people I
love going to universities and having
people really go after me and there's
videos online videos online you could
find them and you can tell that I'm
enjoying it because I really get into it
but yeah I mean it makes it fun for me
right I want to be challenged I once I
keep telling audiences I want you to
come up with a question I've never heard
before
yeah I want I want to be pushed because
it's not fun stagnating even if you
think you know even if you think what
you say is true you don't want to
stagnate tonight you want to keep
pushing the envelope yeah and even this
just idea out there that somehow
Objectivists are all serious or whatever
but we did that event there's video of
it 500 people not only did I have
everyone cheering and screaming and
standing up and go crazy they were we
did this whole funny thing about the
seven Darien words George Carlin I don't
know that ever has thrown at me
everyone screaming all that all the
words and all that and but it goes more
to the point that I think people are
just starved for some reality these days
just having fun yelling out some curses
and it being okay like we've sort of
forgotten how to just be okay with but
there is a bit of craziness
this is perception that if you an
advocate for reason if you're rational
and believe in silence they should've
stuck up here and you don't believe you
know I love emotions right I'm a
passionate guy but I love City Valley
just listening to music and just feeling
you know you live you experience in life
through your emotions and and you got to
value your emotions you got to cultivate
your emotions you got to really you got
to really experience your emotions
emotions are not just just not tools of
cognition you don't discover facts you
don't discover truth emotionally that's
what you use reason for but it doesn't
mean you demean your emotions you put
down your emotions it means you know
their place in your life emotions don't
have to do with truth maybe truth about
me but not truth about the world out
there reason to discover truth you just
need to know what part of yourself
is responsible for what so Objectivists
who understand the philosophy and many
of them don't many of them I mean a lot
of jokes out there a lot of people use
the philosophy to be jokes but
Objectivists to a well-integrated
emotional people you know because they
they they understand the important role
in Motion's playing human life so you
have been bouncing all over the world
I'm honored that you stopped in LA
during this world tour anytime quickly
and it made some of the places that
you've been just in the last few months
I mean you have really been all over the
place well just in the last few months I
I did it two of Asia did I went around
the world yeah yeah so I went for
California I went to Tokyo Kyoto Seoul
South Korea to play a Wang Joo in
Beijing in China Ruhlin Betar in
Mongolia Hong Kong tel-aviv London
Clemson University which I know you're
going to go to in the in the fall and
then back to California and spoke at
every one of those places gave talks to
all in there people in all of those
spaces passionate I've also been as we
talked about too many places in Eastern
Europe
heading back to Tbilisi which in Georgia
I'm glad Baku and Azerbaijan but I've
been to I've been many times on I'm
going back to Kiev and to Warsaw and to
Krakow into Sofia Bulgaria and I was
into Albania and in Montenegro and
Macedonia you know which most people so
many Americans don't even know where
they are on the map
they have my audience thinks you're
making up words right now yeah I hope
that we don't know I might've already
record is a joy I want to stop there
because I'm glad you mentioned Eastern
Europe because that's where I wanted to
go with this because you mentioned to me
a couple weeks ago that you're finding
that in Eastern Europe right now they're
incredibly receptive to these ideas
because they've had so many bad ideas
for so long fest they no longer can
tolerate bad ideas or that they're
starving this is lobbying for something
that they know what they have is wrong
right so what they sow within memory
within a couple of generations maybe
three great they had fascism they've
lived under the Nazis they've had
communism a brutal communism right I
mean their parents were oppressed by
communism and now they just have
corruption they have democracy they vote
but the sense generally in Eastern
Europe is the government is corrupt
everything is is cronyism people and
they look at the West and they see
America they see Germany they see
England they know what's possible in
terms of wealth they know it's possible
in terms of freedom and and they they
want that and and they're looking for
what it is that leads to that and they
know that the alternative and they look
at the European Union and the suspicious
of that to centralize power autocratic
bureaucratic dictating from the top down
so they are I my sense in those places
and I'd add Brazil and some of the Latin
American countries to this as well this
experience so much harder over the last
hundred years the young people you know
college age people high school early 20s
looking for something different and they
were open to new ideas they're willing
to be challenged you're not going to buy
into the Marxist garbage they're not
going to buy into silencing free speech
because it's been there done that right
so when you come to them and talk about
freedom when you come
talk to them about real person
responsibility taking your life
seriously pursuit of happiness they are
open in ways that a rich complacent
college kid in the United States isn't
right Marxism sounds kind of cool I've
never experienced it I don't know any
histories I don't know what it's done in
the world right and I don't even
understand the role of ideas and how
ideas actually impact actions so what
the hell and and I'm really worried
about the next iPhone and whether it's
going to have the features I really want
but I hate capitalism right you know
capitalism is evil but I from know my
god I need that and Twitter and they all
do they also get over the fact that it's
made in China with people being paid
very little yeah they attack me at my
Congress as they read even question of
the right phone right they attack me
hopeful for praising Apple and then they
they go after the Chinese workers but
they're using their phone they have no
there's no respect for the even ideas
that they hold because if they were true
ly held those ideas they give up the
iPhone they'd give up the Samsung
because the same thing with Samsung they
wouldn't use one a technology because
there are years and are consistent with
modern technology but the complacent
life is too good right life is too
comfortable and and it ad so it's
complacency in the one hand the other
thing you notice is that our educational
system in the United States it's hard to
express how bad it really is it is anti
thinking it is anti really using one's
mind it is and it's it's it's all about
emotion it's all about cultivating
emotion not as a way of living but as
experience life but as a tool of
cognition that's knowing really what you
feel is true I mean you see that on the
free speech debate that is a big part of
the free speech debate feelings are
truths and the world there is no
objective reality to whatever I want it
to be whatever I feel it to be that's
the post modernist and that's a
culmination of it so it but that's in
our educational system that's deeply
rooted as you go when you sit down
six-year-olds and ask them what they
think about what they feel about Trump
what is the six-year-old know about
politics
I mean six-year-old should not be
exposed to politics apparently a lot of
the pundits on
their children know these incredible
essays and have such incredible insight
into trouble my kid just said and then
they lay out something that's obviously
the kids but in a class we ask these
kids for opinions about topics that they
know nothing about right you have to
have life experience you have to have
knowledge you and if you don't have an
educational system so looking back to
Eastern Europe the educational systems
in Europe not just in Eastern Europe
believe in the UK and solely in Asia are
just better than ours so the kids know
more they make it how did they get
education systems right if they got so
much fun oh I didn't say they got it
right or not right dad okay better so
what I would say is the educational
system in the world was at a certain
level
going into the 20th century and the
United States adopted progressive
education and went like that went down
right and the rest of the world kind of
punched around in mediocrity which is
where I think they are today so their
educational system a mediocre they're
not good fair bit but they're mediocre
ours is a catastrophe because we took
James Dewey seriously so we imput waste
because he was the first American
philosopher okay everything else came
from Europe finally we found an American
who spoke philosophy we just embraced
him and made one of any any any thought
he was a pragmatic philosophy which
appealed against to some extent of
Americans were action-oriented rather
than intellectually in it so we embrace
this idea of progressive education which
was focused on socializing kids not on
teaching them and not on knowledge so I
think the British system in the European
system is bad because it's too
regimented and in it but it but what
it's good at is conveying knowledge the
American system doesn't convey knowledge
it lets kids but if you're exceptional
you do very well in that system because
you learn yourself and then you're
allowed to innovate so that's why you
get I think the Steve Jobs is the the
real innovators the Silicon Valley types
because it's not regimented and one of
the reasons and that so what you need is
a well calibrated I wouldn't say middle
ground but but what you need is a system
that both conveys knowledge and allows
individuals the children to innovate to
think freely to experiment with ideas so
you mentioned that your passion really
is not
political side of this but the
philosophical side does ultimately it
feeds into everything that becomes
political so what would the right amount
of government be in your estimation
because I hear this all the time also
that well Objectivists are just sort of
fant they're sort of fancy libertarians
yeah something like they're libertarians
that may be excited through a little bit
more or some liberals hands will say
objective this or libertarian you
haven't thought about it enough yes yes
so what in your view would be the rule
well I don't I don't want to I don't
want to position ourselves necessarily
versus libertarians I mean I think one
more philosophical and libertarians
libertarians and but I also don't know
what libertarianism means I think that's
the biggest problem it's a big tent
which includes an algo capitalist some
of them nice and alkyl capitalist like
blind Kaplan who's on this show and some
of them not very nice anarcho-capitalist
the real really bad guys in my view and
we do a lot of damage to Liberty
movement all the way to people who are
kind of conservatives who want a big
role for government as compared to what
I would want but it still consider
themselves Republican libertarian so to
me the whole libertarian thing is kind
of meaningless so I believe that
government has only one rule and
everything needs to be measured on that
and that is to protect the rights of
individuals to protect your right to
life that's the core right to protect
the ability of individuals to pursue the
rational values they need in order to
live and to thrive and to be happy in
the end of the day so what does that
entail well protect them against what
right
well the criminals that are gonna steal
your wallet are going to punch you in
the face you're going to murder you will
rape you they're always going to be
people like that right so you need some
protection entity and that entity is
government it has a monopoly over the
use of atalia Tory force the data
protect you from the criminals so when
an cats say even that could be
privatized that's somewhere where you
say we absolutely not it cannot be
privatized because that is legitimizing
violence that's saying violence oh we
can have a market in violence we can
trade in violence so it's a rejection of
the idea that violence has no place in
civilized humanity they view it just as
another market good I do it as a
different type of thing okay it's
the anti reason so if you focus on the
positive which is reason forces the anti
reason has to be excluded but more than
that what the inalco caps are saying is
the truth what is right about property
rights how we define property rights
truth is something to be negotiated
between protection agencies an objective
says no truth is something to be
discovered by people responsible for
discovering that truth so what are the
boundaries of certain types of property
rights which are hard right intellectual
property rights which are dollar of an
alkyl capitalist reject there all of gum
it's the finals it's it's the it's the
set boundaries of what they actually
mean and and if you disagree with them
then that's what you have a court system
and that's what you have a judiciary
system but but at the end of the day
they have to be experts who define
certain things about so you need a
legislature and then so to define but
it's very now it's the protect property
rights protect individual rights and
then you need a military to protect us
from bad guys
invaders terrorists or whatever but
that's it so you know what about roads
and PO and postal service and things
like so all the postal service I mean I
mean does anybody use the postal service
anymore so you remember privatizing that
I just want to get some of the total of
that one privatized suddenly roads could
be privatized the whole books written on
how to do it I'm not an expert on
privatizing goods and I think it's the
last thing that we need to deal with but
it but I don't think it's that hard
particularly with modern technology to
privatize roads and to charge a fee for
usage on roads and these are easy things
I ate I think the challenging stuff that
people talk about is healthcare and
things like that which I don't think is
challenging because I think I think the
only reason it seems challenging to
people's they lack imagination but III
ask not how would it be not challenging
I can't let you be it's just about
healthcare so easy bit but you know I'll
get to it right yeah okay so I ask
audiences all the time and I have to use
my oh he took my iphone I don't have an
iPhone we took you out of the hive oh
now my iPhone I can use it as a prop
yeah anyway I asked audiences will
pretend you have an iPhone here I think
so here's the iPhone right yes would you
want this design by government committee
what would it look like
and everybody freaks out of course now
we don't know don't let it touch that
right that's okay
what's my important health care or the
iPhone Rojas kids more important and why
would you let an entity you would not
design an iPhone why would you let them
design healthcare system why would you
let them dictate you know what doctors
to see and what treatments to get why
would you let a bunch of bureaucrats who
can't design an iPhone a simple product
like an iPhone deal with a human body
which is a million times more complex or
with education I use the same example
education I don't want to get a touching
education because it's it's too much for
them it's not what they're able to do
why would you want the institution
responsible for force using guns to come
into a hospital I don't want guns in
hospitals I don't want guns in schools
right I'm gonna get the Second Amendment
guys after better I don't want like I
don't want any governing I think when I
see government I see a gun I see force I
see coercion I see or thority the only
place authority belongs is to protect
from people with guns that's it
I don't want that that that you suppose
anywhere else so what is the solution
the solution is to privatize it the
solution is to bring the same kind of
innovation imagination entrepreneurship
into the healthcare space but we have a
silicon valley right imagine if if
doctors viewed themselves as
entrepreneurs and if insurance companies
could offer any product in the world
that they you would have an economists
to you know have come up with these you
would have insurance against
pre-existing conditions you can buy a
product like that it wouldn't be that
hard you have all kinds of definitions I
could call I could customize insurance
policy for me and I would I would use
the marketplace to figure out what
treatments I wanted and didn't want when
that prices would be clearly
identifiable so the solution to
healthcare the problems are we have
today is mostly them just like that's
the solution to any economic issue it's
it's free up the entrepreneurial mind
free up the creators and the builders
and the makers so what though would you
do about all of the people that just
simply can't afford to get in the game
so using your iPhone analogy
obviously not everyone can afford an
iPhone there's going to be a certain
amount of people no matter what now I
understand before Obamacare we took care
of them at the emergency room and it was
not Lisa that's crazy and now we have it
we have a different situation but what
if it's real market would how we pose
people there's no question that he would
look what so before Obamacare 30 million
Americans supposedly couldn't afford
health care to buy to buy health
insurance and then the question was why
and if you looked across states and you
look at the various insurance products
in states like California which
regulated to death exactly what an
insurance company could offer I have to
pay for pregnancy and maternity and
acupuncture I tried acupuncture
I don't like it never going you had it
and a million other things that are
covered my insurance is incredibly
expensive but like they are states and I
can't tell you exactly which ones but in
states that you can go to and get a
simple policy that covered your
emergencies and cost less than a cell
phone bill now how many Americans can
afford a cell phone almost not ninety
something percent of Americans have cell
phones and pay their bill on time and do
and do something like that it it health
insurance should be affordable to
anybody and it could be affordable to
anybody if you've got all these
regulations and all these constraints
and then if you encourage competition
with insurance companies one of the
problems is we have two or three
insurance companies that dominate the
field but that's because they can only
sell a particular package when you
commoditize insurance you give
monopolization what you need is to deke
get rid of the commodity aspect of let
competition ring let people come up with
new innovations and then you get real
competition what does competition do
everywhere in every field dry price it
down and dry quality up and that's and
if you did that there would be nobody
I'm not going to say nobody would have
no insurance somebody with some young
person would say had only to buy
insurance I'm young and I'm
indestructible and you know what and a
certain sliver of people that simply
still cannot see the sliver
couldn't afford it so what do you do
with those people I mean I would say I'd
say the main thing you do with those
people is you provide
with safety net but that safety net
should be provided privately and not a
government a government shouldn't decide
who gets to be part of the safety net
who doesn't we should decide and again I
asked every audience as a video of me
doing this at a school I say how many of
you want to take care a willing to take
a portion of your salary every month and
pay into a fund that takes care of
people who really cannot take care of
themselves every hand in the room goes
up that's it so what's the problem
why do we need a government bureaucratic
come with a gun and collect the money
from you when you are happy to do it
voluntarily and you all see why it's
good for you and it's good for the world
in which you want to live to help those
people who are falling in bad luck or
who can't for whatever reason take care
of themselves right now
so we create a private safety net now I
know I because we talked about this last
time and your listeners are very cynical
Oh nobody would pay in that stuff but
that's just not true in the nineteenth
century in America there was no
government safety net and this country
was relatively poor as compared with
which we are today and immigrants just
flooded that you think the illegal
immigrants from from Mexico some people
think our problem the lot of immigrants
that came into America in the 19th
century far exceeds anything that is
coming from Mexico as a per capita base
they all found jobs or some of them
struggled and family helped them and
others struggled and the community
helped them but the government didn't
intervene and almost nobody I'm not
going to say nobody died in the streets
but almost nobody died of starvation in
the streets today with far richer hmm we
have you know patreon we have mechanisms
to raise money that have never existed
you know there's no question about and
we have these billionaires who have you
know the amount of money that they have
the amount of welcome that is
unimaginable the idea that in a culture
like ours we couldn't afford to take
care of a few people who really can't
take care of themselves isn't ludicrous
to me the idea that we need some
government bureaucrat to decide how much
of our income we'll have to donate this
is bizarre we I mean it may be that
we've just been sort of dumbed into the
mission we've just accepted at this
point that this is how it is so if you
were to say to the average person well
would you give
where they'll say yes but then to
actually take the the notion of I'm
going to now vote for people that are
going to make that a reality is sort of
a bridge too far like it's all in that
it's that a lot of people say this and
this is this is relates a lot of issues
people will say I would do it I know I
would do it ok but they want it right
and I've talked to business owners say I
- knee does not need to be regulated
we're honest we do it right this
competition with that industry they're
all really bad people and they need to
be regulate that and and you see this
projection and this comes from a certain
cynicism about the world but it comes
from certain view of human nature which
again I'm trying to combat and I think
this goes to the core of I want people
to adopt this idea that we can be
rational that we can think for ourselves
that people can take care of themselves
99.9% of humanity can take care of
themselves can feed themselves can
clothe themselves can can live a life
that is successful they're few people
there for genetic reasons or whatever
born incapacitated or accidents happen
to them but if you look at a human being
out there they can take care of
themselves and what they need is to be
taught how and they need to be educated
and then we stop feeling sorry for
themselves and they need to get up on
their feet what a waste of a life to
moan and complain and bitching and
assume that everybody's a bad guy around
and brace like do something positive you
know make something of yourself and
whatever level of ability you have you
know some people have a low IQ or have
or not a strong or whatever whatever
realm you live in
you can make something of your life
that's what that's what I'm about and if
you if that's what you want in life then
the system that makes that possible as a
system of freedom is a system that is
not going to place artificial barriers
in your pursuit of life and as long as
you're not hurting other people you do
what you do and you know what you're
going to fail sometimes failure is part
of life and when you fail you can go to
your neighbor and ask for help and if
you've been a nice guy they will help
you and if you've been a rotten guy they
might not help you that's part of that's
part of
the personal responsibility question
here right and you know take
responsibility for your own life living
don't expect other people to be forced
to help you you don't ever like to pull
a gun on your neighbor and demand the
help somehow that gun goes away when we
vote to take money from our neighbors to
help us know if this is a great point
right some things involve for an
individual to do its Amal for the group
to do so point iron man make great
so if stealing is wrong then stealing is
wrong and it doesn't matter how many
times we vote on it doesn't matter how
many people vote on it it's still
stealing it's still taking using force
taking something away from me that
belongs to me
so if we can just adopt that simple
principle right and if we can if we can
understand and people can accept that
person responsibility you know that
that's the hope I have politically you
know in for the future Your Honor I
usually like to offer guests a chance to
kind of sum up their philosophy and do
it in a nice little bow you beat me to
it I think I think you beat me to it
I do want to add though but can we end
up as I said before neck you know next
time maybe I have Shermer and fragran we
can get you involved in something like
that for that would be fun for another
perspective on but for the record you
have offered to debate plenty of people
that I've had on the show we're going to
do ben shapiro just said that he's
willing to do something with you so
we're going to do that and see if we can
mix this in because I think the next
evolution of the ideas behind the show
are having more of these conversations
yeah and as people can discover on
YouTube I've debated plenty of people so
it's not I don't I don't shun the
debating format I enjoy it and and these
are people I respect so even though I
disagree with many of them one on many
different issues I believe in that
dialogue I believe the only way to
actually move things forward is to
discuss the debate and to use as long as
we all accept the reason is the guide
truth and that's what we're going to
discover truth out there then and yeah
I'm bringing them on it's going to be a
lot of fun are you going to do any of
these events with me in the fall or
you're you're all over the world again
I'm all over the world again I'm
traveling this fall we'll do some events
on campus we'll make it happen
all right very good for more on your own
follow him on the Twitter machine at
around Brooke
[Music]
you